daily fantasy sports the most addictive
thing you can do on your phone other
than perhaps cocaine if you own a
television you cannot have missed their
ads get to draftkings.com right now for
one day games and let you win daily
vanduul packs the thrill of a whole
season into just one week for FanDuel
there's no season-long commitment are
your dreams big enough to cash a giant
check play free with promo code drops
enter promo code youtube' 60 use the
promo code clean 6 enter promo code bang
9 yes daily fantasy sports combine
everything dudes love sports money and a
lack of commitment and I will say I was
like the promo code really gives it an
air of exclusivity it's like you've just
joined an elite supper club whose
password is bang 9 it's been impossible
to avoid those ads a few months ago
the two main daily fantasy sites
draftkings and FanDuel were airing a
national TV ad every 90 seconds you only
need to remind people of something that
often if your target market is
sports-loving goldfish now for those who
don't know let me quickly explain to you
what daily fantasy is until fairly
recently fantasy sports used to be a
season-long game where you and your
co-workers picked imaginary teams of
players put $20 each in a pot and
eventually lost to Janice in accounting
which would have been extremely
upsetting and I'll tell you why she
don't give a bad sport but Denny Lee
fantasy is very different with daily
fantasy you can go online typically pay
an entry fee of anything from 25 cents
to thousands of dollars a pick a team
for just a week or a day and compete
against total strangers it's the same as
season-long fantasy the way a nice mug
of tea is the same as a nice baggie of
heroin both give you a lovely warm
feeling one's a little more intense and
many TV networks are not just airing
daily fantasy ads they're making deals
with these companies we should know at
NBC Sports Group and NBC's parent
company Comcast are among the investors
in FanDuel this is something I should
disclose the 21st Century Fox owns a
stake and draftkings
at CNN's parent company Time Warner has
made an investment in FanDuel as a
matter of disclosure ESPN has an
exclusive two-year marketing agreement
with draftkings worth reported two
hundred and fifty million dollars Wow at
this point there is almost no show that
is not financially compromised by a
relationship with daily fantasy
including yell at your daughter till she
dances on lifetime in fact in fact just
so you know HBO is a subsidiary of Time
Warner which means that this joke about
being compromised is in a sense brought
to you by fandoms and I'll say thanks
guys and it's not just TV networks some
of the sports leagues themselves have
closely partnered with these sites the
NBA is an equity stake in fan d'Or MLB
has won in draft kings and many NFL
teams have advertising deals with the
fantasy sites in fact twenty-eight of
the NFL's 32 teams have sponsorship
deals with either draft kings or FanDuel
and the cowboys and the Patriots owners
are both investors in draft kings and of
course of course in a way leagues and
networks like the idea of daily fantasy
it's frankly the only thing that's going
to make people want to watch the Bucs
and the Jaguars face off on a rainy
Thursday night because no one is
watching just to witness the majesty of
Tampa Bay kicker Connor bath unless you
are Connors mom and even then she might
DVR it
I'm sorry Connor but it is Thursday it's
scandal nights I've got Shonda Lange's
right through have a good kick I hope
you kick good but but it is it's a
little weird to see professional sports
in cahoots with these sites because most
leagues have generally been opposed to
gambling unlicensed gambling is illegal
in most states and these sites do look a
lot like gambling and don't just take
that from me take it from a Hall of Fame
quarterback Joe Namath do you feel like
it's gambling is that what you do with
it
we're saying the play
you have to pay and do they win
something they do that's gambling okay
okay okay so Joe labor a man so lacking
in discernment he wore this to the Super
Bowl even he can see that this is
gambling and he's not alone
just last month the Gaming Control Board
of Nevada ruled it was gambling
essentially arguing if people are going
to lose all their money pressing buttons
on a screen that screen better have Sex
and the City characters on it and just
this week there was another development
big trouble for those daily fantasy
sports sites FanDuel and draftkings New
York's Attorney General says they amount
to illegal gambling yes the New York
Attorney General is attempting to shut
down daily fantasy in the state and if
that happens the best way to gamble here
will once again be buying meat on a
stick from a guy with a cart
why does my chicken have whiskers do you
know what I'm hungry I'm rolling the
dice but both major daily fantasy sites
insist that they've done nothing wrong
in fact draftkings even claims on its
website that it's 100% legal which is
immediately suspicious if the guy at
TCBY said this frozen yogurt is 100%
legal
you would know that somehow it was a
product of the illegal sex trade and
both companies bristle at the very word
gambling insisting that they are
something far more benign you don't view
what you do here at FanDuel as gambling
yeah that's a word that isn't used very
much around here I take it because we
are every time that you talk to our
users what comes through loud and clear
is the fact that we're an entertainment
product okay okay sure but but you know
what else is an entertainment product
gambling gambling is incredibly
entertaining until of course you're down
15 grand to a Russian entertainment
syndicate
but when draftkings in particular claims
that it's not gambling it's worth noting
that not only have they applied for and
received a gambling license in the UK
but according to the Nevada Attorney
General their website once had search
engine optimization phrases with
multiple instances of the word betting
and sites usually use alt text like that
to tell search engines what they are
it's why this shows website is tagged
with British nerd brick dork
news goof and birdie fact funny man so
so here's the question how fast
draftkings say they are not gambling and
100% legal
well daily fantasy sites often point to
one particular piece of legislation the
2006 unlawful internet gambling
Enforcement Act or UI gea
right now of course fantasy sports being
a game of skill is carved out of UI gea
and permissible and most states in the
u.s. I just think under the current law
right now it's very obvious that this
fits within skill gaming now what he's
referring to in his charismatic monotone
sleep-inducing voice is that in 2006
when Congress passed a law to crack down
on online gambling it exempted fantasy
sports which remember back then which is
those office things that you lost to
Janice in accounting it was meant to be
a very small exception but through that
small carve out two multi-billion dollar
businesses have emerged
it's like those law makers built a
doggie door for a beloved pooch and then
daily fantasy came bursting through like
a pack of wolves say we are dogs it's a
doggie door right that's for us we're
legally dogs woof right tell them woof
step aside wool but even the guy who
co-wrote that law says it wasn't meant
to apply to what fantasy sports have now
become the US congressman who drafted
the 2006 legislation used by draftkings
and FanDuel as proof of their legitimacy
is upset former lawmaker Jim leach says
it is quote sheer shut spa for the daily
fantasy sports sites to pretend the law
makes them legal okay okay okay but
first of all shut spa it's actually
pronounced Claude spur but but but but
the idea the idea that daily fantasy
sites are using this law to claim
they're not gambling is not hot but it's
horseshit because does that law
interestingly that law never said
fantasy sports were legal it just said
they weren't explicitly illegal under
that specific law but that each state's
gambling laws would continue to apply
and in general most states determine
whether or not something is gambling by
asking whether it's more of a game of
chance or more a game of skill and if
being a game of chance could make you
gambling and therefore illegal it's no
wonder that daily fantasy sites like to
describe themselves like this they are a
games of skill and we can prove that
through data that we have of skills
predominant factor in the game then it's
a game of skill and we can show that our
game like traditional fantasy sports it
is skilled predominant it's it's legally
critical to these companies that they be
perceived as games of skill that's why
every time I talk you hear the word
skills more often than during an
underground rap battle in fact just this
Friday daily fantasy supporters actually
held a protest rally outside the New
York Attorney General's Office with a
familiar chant hey hey hey
now if you're thinking it's a little odd
that ordinary fans were chanting
something so legally specific there may
actually be a reason for that behind me
this morning they're about 250 people
here they blocked the sidewalk a lot of
police a lot of protesters making a lot
of noise but a hundred of those 250
people who are employees of Fandral
themselves because they're officers are
right here in Union Square
they used their own employees as
protesters if you are trying to make the
argument that you're not a shady
gambling-related company maybe don't
openly stack the deck in your favor
which is not to say that daily fantasy
does not involve skill it actually might
involve a lot more skill than they would
like you to be aware of because this
summer a study revealed some shocking
numbers 91% of the profits were won by
just the top 1.3 percent of players
during the first half of the baseball
season 85 percent of players were losers
eighty-five percent of fantasy players
were losers which is staggering in the
general population that number is 40
percent at best it essentially breaks
down like this 40 percent loses 40
percent 14 percent weirdos five
percent decent human beings and then of
course Beyonce and if if you are
wondering what it takes to be part of
that big winning 1% let me show you
Albertson made over $200,000 play in
fantasy sports last year in drafting his
fantasy teams Albertson spends hours
each day studying his own homemade
algorithms that track thousands of
up-to-the-minute statistics and player
projections projections that even factor
in the hourly weather forecasts and wind
conditions in each stadium this is every
pitcher basically in baseball you've got
dozens of rows of statistics yes
fancy sports are effectively dominated
by numbers nerds with sophisticated
algorithms which is great news for
anyone who wished Moneyball could
somehow be a bit more boring but but
it's not great news
for a casual player and it's somewhat
undercuts the key selling point in their
ads anybody can win it's not just a game
for professionals it's a game for
everybody and fan duels made it where
anybody can play anybody can succeed
yeah but anybody can succeed is a bit of
a stretch when only one percent of the
players are winning most of the money to
say anyone can succeed on daily fantasy
is a bit like saying that I could be the
next James Bond sure it's a mathematical
possibility but it's a long shot it's a
it's a different movie not better or
worse just different so these daily
fantasy sites may be in a bit of a
quandary under our hazey gambling laws
the more they're a game of skill the
stronger their legal case usually is but
the less appealing they become to the
average player and there's actually a
precedent for an online amalgam of skill
and chance
unfortunately for daily fantasy it's
poker which which most states consider
gambling and you would think if these
sites were smart they would run away as
fast as they could from any comparison
to poker so if you go and play
draftkings it actually in many ways has
a similar feel to poker the games have
payout structures that are similar and
you know there's a lot of different
variety where you can play head to head
all the way up to larger tournaments the
way he's describing daily fantasy in
poker is so similar most people could
not tell them apart
they're like alligators and crocodiles
or Amy Adams and Isla Fisher it are
those two different people or the same
person twice it's impossible to tell
nobody knows and the similarities
between online poker and daily fantasy
don't stop there remember Cory Albertson
the guy with the homemade algorithm
guess where he honed those skills in a
past life he was a professional poker
player he's all-in and in trouble
against Cory Albertson both with a pair
of jacks Albertan but then he discovered
daily fantasy sports and has been
winning big against his online opponents
ever since look if it attracts the same
people and requires the same sorts of
skills it's safe to say it is somewhat
similar it's like finding out an Olympic
gymnast has joined circus
like or or an Olympic snowboarder has
joined a Colorado pot dispensary there's
there's connective tissue there that's
all I'm saying
and in case it's connection to the world
of Poker was not clear enough guess who
was a sponsor of the World Series of
Poker this year the World Series of
Poker Main Event telecast presented by
draftkings they're basically saying if
you love gambling
you'll love draftkings for completely
unrelated reasons look by any rational
definition daily fantasy is gambling
which which isn't necessarily a bad
thing people clearly love it but if
we're going to defacto legalize sports
gambling across the u.s. we should at
least do it on purpose and not because
two companies of somehow weaseled out a
way to pretend that they are not
something that they clearly are because
gambling enterprises wherever they are
legal are regulated to protect people
and that's going to need to happen here
and until such time if they're going to
keep bombarding us with those ads they
should at least make them a little more
honest daily fantasy is the hottest new
way to make real money as soon as I
tried drive Kings I was hooked
I've been using Fandral since I saw
those commercials on TV all the time I
turned thirty five dollars into two
million dollars into 40 dollars into
zero dollars on FanDuel daily fantasy is
the best I get to play every day you
mean you get to gamble it's not gambling
oh it's definitely gambling you have a
massive gambling problem it's actually a
skills-based game that is gonna make us
rich one day you're an idiot
with daily fantasy anyone can win I've
won seven hundred and eighty four
thousand dollars on FanDuel see you can
compete against millions of regular
sports fans just like you I have a
master's degree in statistics and have
designed an advanced algorithm that
incorporates real-time weather condition
updates and can calculate an earned run
average to the 20th decimal point B just
how does it feel to be a nerds
daily fantasy sports is the only
skills-based entertainment product where
you can win big money you're where I'm a
winner how are you a winner uh-huh come
on winner I'll tell you how to I'm a
winner I want six dollars and 18 cents
playing daily fantasy that's all I'm a
winner
you spent $1,200 well that's what you
got to do you spend money to make money
I may be six dollars and 18 cents you
spent $1,200 yeah that's how it works I
don't understand you it cuz you don't
understand sports you
I understand math don't listen to the
critics daily fantasy is a legitimate
business daily fantasy has the support
of the NFL when have they ever been
associated with anything shady the best
part about it is that it's currently
legal so I'm excited about that
look at the size this check here we go
check look at this check $1,200 and you
want six dollars in 18 cents you saying
I'm not a big winner you spent $18
printing out this check at Kinkos well I
was proud that I won and look who the
chick is made up to big winner your
husband oh why don't you put it
where the TV used to go daily
fantasy sports it's just pure fun and
it's so simple I just watch football and
win money I know that sounds too good to
be true in fact even saying it out loud
now I'm realizing that can't possibly be
true you mean a minute I hate you so
much daily fantasy is not just fun Who I
am
what'd the guy do I'm gonna turn this
into a full-time career I'm pregnant and
if you're concerned the daily fantasy
sounds like gambling
don't worry it isn't it's not gambling
it's playing a game where my cash
winnings depend on the performance of
professional athletes wait I described
gambling again didn't I
with daily fantasy all you need is a
love of sports I think I just realized
it at this very moment I actually hate
you fantastic I hate me too so that's
something we agree on for the first time
in a while is there something stronger
than a divorce that we could get like a
super divorce there was we probably
couldn't afford it play daily fantasy
now just use promo code gambling or
promo code obviously gambling or promo
code exploiting a legal loophole but by
any common-sense definition this is
gambling
you